okay today I'm going to talk to you
about conservation of mass we're going
to see how mass is conserved by looking
at different types of reaction so first
of all it's important to know what
conservation of mass means conservation
means stay in the same mass is just
talking about the mass of the particles
within a reaction so the absolute golden
rule that we need to know it's in a
reaction no atoms are created or
destroyed now this is the underlying
principle behind conservation of mass we
can't have atoms suddenly appearing or
atoms suddenly disappearing they just
move from one form into another form so
we're going to look at to begin with
when we have an experiment where the
mass measurement stays the same so right
here we have a precipitation reaction
where we have two solutions added
together and we have a solid being
formed so we have copper sulfate and
sodium hydroxide solutions mixed
together to make copper hydroxide and
sodium sulfate now if I just draw this
right now underneath we can get the idea
of this type of reaction so let's
imagine here's an electronic balance
let's say at the beginning of the
experiment it reads a hundred grams now
what we've got here is we've got a
conical flask with a bong in the top
like that now what we've done before we
put the bung in we put in our copper
sulfate and we put in our sodium
hydroxide okay now as you can see during
this experiment let's say it started at
a hundred grams this experiment the mass
reading at the end will also be a
hundred grams the reason for that is
atoms cannot be created or destroyed
so therefore if we've started with this
mass we're going to finish with the same
mass even though there's been a chemical
reaction happening because the bonds is
none of the mass has been lost at all in
any way
so none has been spilt none has exited
so if we start with a hundred grams we
finished with a hundred grams as well so
the mass has been conserved it stayed
the same now this isn't always what
appears to be happening because we can
do reactions where the mass measurement
appears to decrease now this doesn't
mean that atoms have been destroyed
because we might think if mass has gone
down that atoms have been destroyed so
let's have a look how this works so
again a similar kind of setup we've got
an electronic balance and on top of the
electronic balance we've got a conical
flask okay now this time notice there's
no bung in the top of the conical flask
so this time we've got solid calcium
carbonate reacting with hydrochloric
acid to make calcium chloride which is a
solution and water and carbon dioxide so
notice here here's my calcium carbonate
and I add in my hydrochloric acid so
there's the hydrochloric acid going in
which is a solution now let's say I
start off with a hundred grams it reads
on there on the balance now over time as
these react this mass is going to go
down that doesn't mean atoms are being
destroyed now the secret for what's
going on is we have to look at this here
our carbon dioxide as you can see by
this state symbol carbon dioxide is a
gas so what's happening is as these
react together my calcium carbonate at
my hydrochloric acid some gas particles
are actually being lost to the
surroundings so some of my carbon
dioxide is actually being lost therefore
even though this may go down so let's
say after a while it might be 80 instead
of 100 it's gone down that does not mean
those atoms have been destroyed it just
means they've been lost to the
surroundings as a gas
so whenever we have a gas being produced
in a reaction we may well have a mass
measurement going down but that doesn't
mean particles have been destroyed now
the third and final example we're going
to look at is when the mass mass
measurement appears to increase appears
to go up so here let's have a look at a
different type of reaction we've got
magnesium reacting with oxygen to make
magnesium oxide so let's imagine at the
beginning of this experiment we have an
electronic balance again and in there
we've zeroed this off so in there we've
got a crucible so that's just a little
kind of container and within there
there is our magnesium now at the
beginning this might mean the magnesium
alone might weigh 1.08 grams so not
yeah just one point zero eight grams now
what we could do is we could react this
magnesium by putting it on top of a
tripod that's a tripod that's a gauze
there's the crucible with the magnesium
inside and we heat it up with a Bunsen
burner we take the lid off so the oxygen
can get in now over time what's
happening as we can see oxygen is a gas
so oxygen is in the air around around
around us so as we heat it up and lift
this lid off the oxygen from the air
comes in and it reacts with the
magnesium to make magnesium oxide so as
we can see this is going to increase in
mass none of that magnesium has gone
anywhere and it's reacted with oxygen
from the air so it's going to increase
in mass as the the particles from the
air react with the magnesium so after
the experiment after all of its reacted
and we've remesh the mass of the
magnesium or of the products we now
instead of having just magnesium on its
own we have
magnesium oxide in there so what's
happened is this will appear to increase
the mass it could for example be 1.80
grams now instead now again that doesn't
mean that atoms have been created it
just means these oxygen molecules these
oxygen atoms from the air have reacted
with the magnesium increasing the mass
so therefore this mass measurement has
increased so that is how conservation of
mass works looking at three different
types of reaction thank you